hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les restes 5 millions si stockton devant
clem lundi d'accord je voudrais juste je
m'adresser à celui qui a trouvé les
vêtements seal parce que les jeunes sont
habillés comme ça aujourd'hui qu'ils
sortent un peu du lot 7 5 représente au
vous commencez à vous lisez le prompteur
première réplique way ce molosse d'aller
avec voteront jane harman au gymnase
charles manque d'ailleurs on aurait dit
les visiteurs des voeux et bien sûr le
voyage de gilles verdez et jean michel
maire au japon j'aimerais qu'on remette
les maris qu'on remette cette chanson
bien sûr year bio des foules mais elle
va prendre tout son sens on va faire
entrer mokhtar en geisha sur cette
musique et vous allez voir chez vous
vous allez vous dire tout soit on
possède la poésie c'est rabelais ses
visions ben oui mokhtar en geisha
mais
[Applaudissements]
j'ai la tête du gars fait très peur on
va vous appeler mokhtar il y en a un qui
a été désigné pour être en pépito
pendant toute l'émission c'est thierry
moreau c'est vous qui avez décidé et
bien pepito il est là applaudissements
polis
[Musique]
epito te mana merci c'est bon merci oui
aïe pepito des bellaing c'est très drôle
il paraît que tournage des visiteurs 3
va débuter en avril christian hiesse
vous pouvez nous en dire un petit peu
plus ou pas sur sur ça
[Applaudissements]
comme souvent à genoux c'est lui des
bonbons il ne mangera moment il est
moins de 50 ans oui c'est bien un homme
était derrière moi non le tournage va
débuter le gérant y à quoi joue au
lavage la solitude
il a presque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]